[Music]
one this is Kevin from the chess website
calm today we're going to be going over
the gioco piano and this is actually the
oldest recorded opening in chess dating
back to the early 16th century starts
out similar to the roy lopez which we've
studied in our last video but as you'll
see the lines are much much different
than a real a Lopez style of play so
we'll go ahead and get into it and talk
about some of the things you may see in
the gioco piano starts out white pawn to
e4 black responds pawn to e5 Y develops
his Knight to f3 taking away Center
control here an attacking pawn on e5
black continues his development Knight
to c6 again attacking the center and
defending his pawn and white chooses to
bring his Bishop to c4 as you probably
remember and the roy lopez the bishop
comes here to pin down the night and the
gioco piano he actually moves it to c4
still lying down this weakness on f7
putting his bishop on this nice long
diagonal and here black is going to
bring his bishop out to c5 and this is
actually the position that comes to the
gioco piano and basically why it has a
lot of different options to the the main
objective here as you can see for both
sides is to control the center White's
Bishop and pawn are both attacking this
d5 score eventually black would like to
thrust his pawn forward to the d5 square
controlling white also would like to
bring his pawn in the middle as you can
see black has two defenders on the d4
square right now white only has one
defender so the mainline continues for
why to add another defender to this d4
square for this thrust that he'll
eventually want is going to be pawn to
c3
now white has many options he can do but
for the most part you were going to see
almost exclusively black develop his
Knight to f6 bringing into the game
putting more pressure on this d5 square
center control and also defending or
excuse me in attacking this e4 square at
the moment we're going to go ahead and
disregard this efore square and we're
going to go ahead and continue the
mainline with our first
our first thought which is going to be
to thrust forward with the d4 square
obviously before we said we only had one
defender in the night defending the d4
square but now we've added this pawn
here so in this variation we see black
take with his pawn captures and white
captures with his pawn and here brings a
lot of different variations that you
will see for the most part we're gonna
go ahead and just talk about some of the
key concepts here white has very good
center control he has both his pawns in
the center his knight and queen are both
protecting this d4 square black has his
minor pieces out trying to attack the
center kind of a modern-style defense
here White has his bishop developed here
attacking this f7 square and also
defending this d5 score in case black
tries to thrust his pawn forward which
he eventually will to free his even if
he moves it to d6 he wants to free up
this Bishop here so he can get in the
action and both of these Knights are
attacking these pawns now obviously you
see that black can come in here and in
capture and we will get into that but
one of the first things you will see
here since we are attacking blacks
Bishop is black first can't take this
because we will take his bishop a lot of
times you'll see black coming in and
check the white king and black really or
excuse me white really has two options
here the first one we're going to go
over they can lead to a pretty
interesting trap here is simply Knight
to c3 and a lot of times from here you
will see black come in
and basically put a pin this night here
cannot move and so black is going to
come in now and take this pawn now
eventually black would like to preserve
his bishops and bring in and take this
knight and then bring his Bishop and
attack and fork both of the King and
rooks we're gonna go ahead and Castle
kingside now again there are multiple
variations we're gonna go over a couple
of those but I'm just showing you some
of the possibilities that can happen in
this case you'll normally see black go
ahead and capture again he wants to hold
on to his bishop pair we're gonna go
ahead and take back in black we're
actually sacrificing a pawn here and
black is gonna go ahead and take that
now it doesn't have to but he's gonna be
eyeing down this rook now you would
normally think that white would have to
move this or he's going to take it but
we're actually gonna disregard that and
set up our trap and that is simply Queen
to b3 and this does a few things one it
attacks this black Bishop so he's gonna
have to move he obviously can move and
take this pawn and we can just take
obviously as you can see we are eyeing
this f7 square that we've got added
protection from so he's got to do
something more than likely he's going to
try to take as much material as he can
and that's going to be in the form of
Bishop to a1 and here our trap is
Unleashed we can go ahead and check the
King here on f7 and then as he moves
obviously he could move his King to e7
but then we can go ahead and bring our
Bishop and easily fork the Queen
so normally you'll see the king move
here to f8 and then we can go ahead and
bring in our Bishop into the action
attacking the Queen you'll normally see
Black has to move his knight here and
then white can move his rook to e1
basically his knight is pinned down to
the Queen eventually we can easily come
in here the King cannot move you can't
capture or it can't move either these
places eventually we will come in here
and we will be able to take the Queen so
keep that in mind that is one very crazy
variation that you may see but a lot of
those moves are I wouldn't say forced
but logical one on both sides so we're
going to get into another variation here
and that is simply in instead of the
knight capturing is just simply the
bishop capturing and from this variation
white can go ahead and instead of taking
here he can go ahead and start moving
forward attacking the center here he is
gambit it off this pawn and given giving
it up now black is going to have to
choose is he want to lose his knight or
does he want to lose this bishop here
more than likely he's going to sacrifice
his knight and hold on to his bishop
since earlier on they are more powerful
so a lot of times you'll see him move
back to f6 preserving this and now we
can take this knight but we're actually
going to do another move developing more
pieces getting them into the action and
move
rook to e1 pinning down this Knight onto
the King and attacking again both of
these Knights so we're not rushing our
attack we're not capturing when we have
to we're building up slowly our attack
as you can see we have given up a pawn
to black and exchange we have grey
development we've already canceled we
have our Bishop and we have a nice pawn
here on d5 attacking we have our rook
lined up on the e-file that's open
attacking the King
so from here black can choose which
which Knight he's going to lose more
than likely he will move this one you
never want to have your King open on a
file when it's captured you'll lose a
tempo here so a lot of times black will
just retreat this knife and you'll see
blood or excuse me white come in and
take and from here White has he's down
material but he's gained a lot of
material advantage as far as all his
pieces are almost developed black it's
kind of cramped back here so why should
have a very good game and last we are
going to look at one more variation and
that's from the very beginning and that
is the Evans gambit that you can play as
white and that simply is again our first
instinct we're going to want to play C
3/2 and then D for thrusting for getting
that extra defender and we know that
once we play more than likely they're
going to develop their knight and give
our pawn on e4 little trouble so we're
going to go ahead and give up a pawn
here to this Bishop Bishop we'll go
ahead and take here and then we can go
ahead and first thrust forward with c3
preparing for this d4 move
as bishop moves back we're going to
thrust forward with our d4 initiative
obviously this Knight is defending on c3
now this is similar to before but black
no longer has this knight on f6 so as
you can see here we have great Center
control we have a nice defense on this
d4 square our knight is defending our
Bishop is on a nice square here
attacking the f7 square so we have very
good center control good development and
we've sacrificed one pawn so these are
some of the things you may see in the
gioco piano I hope you guys enjoyed
learned a lot check out the different
videos and please subscribe so you know
when the new ones are coming out have a
good one